guys it's the first weekend of January
and you know what that means a horror
film if you've been watching my videos
over the past like I don't know four or
five six years January always starts
with a horror film last year woman in
black - the year before that Paranormal
Activity the mark ones the year before
that Texas Chainsaw 3d and the forest is
continuing that tradition and they
almost always suck this film is about a
girl played by Natalie Dormer who is
looking for her twin sister who's gone
missing in a forest in Japan that's
notorious for being a place that people
go to end their lives
she makes the journey to Japan to try to
find her sister meets up with a few
people to help guide her through this
forest and then all the crazy ghost
faces that you could possibly imagine
pop out at her a lot so I went into this
movie with very low expectations in fact
almost all of me expected to hate this
movie but I was kind of excited to go
because it's the first movie of the year
and I love doing what I do
it'd be really easy for me to hate on
this movie it'd be super super easy
right now to just sit back and go yes
movies terrible I hated and here's all
the reasons not that about it isn't
necessarily good but it did surprise me
and it is a cut above your average
January starting off horror film that
we've had over the past many years it is
most certainly better than the ones that
I've reviewed over the past few years
and a lot of that is due to the fact
that you can tell the director of this
movie does have a passion for what he's
doing and he is actually able to create
some genuine sequences of suspense there
were actually moments of this movie that
I was slightly on edge and I did kind of
give a shit like let's say there was a
power outage halfway through this movie
and I couldn't find out what happened I
would have been disappointed I did want
to see what happened in this story I was
interested in our main character and
that honestly shocked me because I was
so ready to see the shittiest horror
film of the year and it's not gonna be
there's gonna be more I'm sure know like
I said this is not a great movie in fact
I wouldn't even really call it a good
movie it has problems and it just
surprised me it took me off-guard the
movie wasn't a complete disaster the
performances in the movie are mostly
fine and that's really the best I can
say about them they don't really go
above or beyond they're a bit workman
like they work for this movie and for
the scenes that are in the
home but you never feel like they're
really going deeper than they could
they're just fine sometimes I was
actually invested in some of the more
frightening scenes but then there were
other times where it just becomes oh she
woke up from a dream
oh she woke up from another dream oh she
just woke up from another dream and
you're like okay I get it dreams and you
have to have something scary that
happens in between the talking part but
my biggest issue with this movie is the
last ten minutes there is an absurd
amount of shaky cam where someone's
running through the woods for like a
minute and a half straight and you're
just like oh my god I'm going to vomit
please just hold the camera straight for
a second how hard is it to have a
Steadicam it just uses Steadicam please
look I have one this is called a
Steadicam it it's very helpful it can do
things for you but it's not just the
execution of the last few minutes that
bug me it's the resolution I won't spoil
it if you haven't seen the film of
course you guys know me it's just that
the film sets up answers that are
intriguing but then the film has no idea
of how to answer them and it sometimes
doesn't even attempt to answer them and
we're some horror films that are more
cerebral like say for instance The
Shining might have an element or a shot
towards the end it just makes your brain
start working and makes you feel uneasy
and it's not necessarily answered but it
works because the entire film feels as
if it still works even with that last
shot which is what I'm talking about the
last shot of the shining makes you go
like what and then you just feel uneasy
all of a sudden with the forest it feels
more like they were trying to set up
intriguing scenes and make you feel
invested and make you feel compelled by
missing information or strange
occurrences but then they never try to
answer those scenes and it just feels
like they were writing something to try
to make it more interesting than it was
without ever trying to answer it but I
must stress that I actually did care for
the most part about these characters
despite the ending that didn't have
enough resolution and it felt a little
bit like it didn't make sense there were
some really good ideas with this movie
involving a viewmaster do you guys
remember view masters yeah one of these
things special thanks to the makers of
the force for actually sending this to
me you know it's it's creepy in a way it
actually ties in to our hero's plight
and her past they do flesh her out well
and there are times where it really
works
and I can't say that this is a terrible
movie it is disappointing in the way
that it ends if there was more
resolution I might actually be
recommending this movie to you it does
fall into that tired clich dream
sequence
Ghostface Wow moments that are seen that
a thousand times enough with these
things but it is a cut above your
average horror film that starts out the
year of January and that's why I'm gonna
give the forest a C+ it did surprise me
you don't necessarily have to run out
and see this movie it's not really all
that great but if you have a day where
it's rating or you don't have anything
else to do and you want to watch an okay
disposable horror movie maybe check out
on blu-ray one day in the future so guys
I have two really cool things to tell
you as I promised I would set up a Q&A
email for you to send me some questions
for a future Q&A because I want to give
you guys something cool because 500,000
subscribers is amazing and I thank you
so much for that you can send me any
question you want at questions for
stuckman at yahoo.com send me your
questions there and within the next
month or so a few weeks I will create an
answers video for you guys questions for
stuckman at yahoo.com also this is super
super huge for me ever since I was in
elementary school I have been writing I
started out writing on notepads I wrote
stupid scary goosebumps like stories and
I've loved writing ever since I've
always dreamt of a time that I could
physically go to a bookstore and see a
book that was written by me that I
created and was able to actually look at
it and hold it well that's coming up
very soon the very cool people at mango
media publishing contacted me about a
book that they wanted me to write they
had the title set up already they had
the idea set up already and when they
asked me if I would want to write this
book I was so flattered the film buffs
bucket list it's about 50 movies
released from the year 2000 to 2015 that
I feel you must see they already came up
with the title and when they came to me
about that I was just like of course
absolutely so I spent the last few
months writing that book in my spare
time it is going to be released in March
I have left the Amazon pre-order link in
the description below if anyone wants to
support me in regards to reading my book
trust me it will not go unnoticed I
swear I thank you so much for all the
support you've given me over the years
it truly is a dream come true that I was
able to write a book and I hope that in
the future I'll be able to write my own
original story as well and get that
published because that's my ultimate
goal this book I I just I I honestly I I
can't believe it
it's a it's a dream come true for me
truly so that link is in the description
below I am endlessly grateful for your
support thank you guys so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes